hello everyone and welcome to a great
game from round one of this year's video
World Cup I was going over the games and
I was looking for one to really Dazzle
you guys uh this one is very special as
it features a move uh uh simply both of
the grand Masters missed it's not an
easy move to find and you guys will have
a a really hard time spotting this one
but I thought it would make a great
pause the video moment and uh it's it
really makes you think outside of the
box to figure out this one so Indian
Grandmaster hashabara takoti versus a
Canadian Grandmaster 11 panzolaya uh
We've covered a lot of games by
hashabara but I think we've only covered
one by eleven it was uh a few years ago
he defeated Magnus Carlsen can't really
remember where could be the world rapid
Championship or something like that but
uh obviously uh uh definitely a strong
player now that being said let's check
it out we have Pawn to D4 by Harsha
barakatakoti and now Ponte G6 11 goes
for the modern defense we've discussed
it a few days ago when official was
playing against the the creator of the
modern defense you of course know who
that is upon to C4 we have Bishop to G7
and now Pawn to E4 we have Pawn to D6 uh
the standard setup of the modern defense
and now Knight to C3 we have C5 and now
Ponte D5
are attacking the uh the pterodactyl
defense which uh with the sort of the
benoni gambits trying to get black to
capture on C3 and it's not the most
common move you will see here there are
many moves that can be played here I
could go a6b5 E6 Knight to F6 like all
of these are very natural moves Knight
to D7 but Bishop captures and C3 check
is uh actually the fourth fourth most
popular move in this position and you
should know it I remember uh that it was
a long long time ago maybe 11 years ago
we were playing the Croatian team
championship and uh we helped our board
one prepare for his match on board one
and of course he knew that uh the I
don't know he who he was playing against
with the white pieces maybe
um yeah I think was maybe feeding master
and then I could be wrong but I think it
was against him and he was playing this
with white piece and we prepared this uh
funky line with Bishop captures and C3
and he was uh well he was really caught
off guard with this bishop captures on
C3 move because you you don't expect a
player with the black pieces to just
part with his strong Bishop with his
dragon and um and chances are you you've
never played against that in the end our
board one lost at the game but he really
really had him struggling he spent like
he was down to a few minutes on the
clock our board one had over an hour and
a half and then he just blundered
terribly as it usually happens but okay
B captures on C3 and now Pawn to E5 so
you got rid of your dark Square Bishops
uh Bishop but now your opponent will
have uh some problem uh developing his
own light Square Bishop with all of his
pawns on light squares so Bishop to D3
we have Knight to D7 and now Pawn to F4
and there is a game where he captures on
F4 was played but here we have Queen to
F6 and it is now as of move 8 that we
have a completely new game
uh so how do you react to this of course
uh 11 wants to capture an F4 to put
pressure on C3 so about Dakota just
plays Knight to E2 guard the C3 pawn
queen to H4 with check and now G3 this
does somewhat weaken why it's king side
even further uh but you know uh for
example if you've played the king's
Gambit that this doesn't really offer
black that much Queen t7 we have castles
and now Pawn to H5 you've created a
weakness and now you want to hone in on
that weakness
um and attack it we have Pawn to F5 you
can already see it's move 12 but this is
not a friendly game this is already
quite to the battle uh G captures an f5e
captures and now Pawn to F6 uh usually a
very dangerous move to play but here you
just close the position and uh say okay
my king will remain here I'm gonna
weaken your center with B5 and then I'm
gonna play H4 at some point and really
put pressure on your uh on your king and
the engine really loves Rook D1 move
here but uh unless you're an engine you
don't play rookie E1 I I try to
understand what the engine wants with
Rook D1 I just have no idea maybe rookie
want the E4 to maybe guard against Ponte
H4 in the future but other than that
it's really hard hard to understand the
move so here King the H1 was played it's
a very nice human move clearing the G1
Square for the Knight the idea is of
course Knight G1 to F3 the H4 and then
the G6 at some point if of course you
allow it we have a queen to G7 and now
Knight to G1 preparing the knights
Journey with Knight to the E7 and now
Knight to F3 and here just Queen to G4
uh it's a very annoying uh Square for
for white to have the black queen on
Bishop back to E2 you can't just wait
here if you just wait here and do
nothing B5 is coming and then a white
will just be under a lot a whole lot of
pressure so here we have Bishop to E2
now threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries and you can't just ignore
this you have to play I've already
removed the queen T4 capture on F5 if
you just continue which your plan Knight
G4 traps the queen and that's it black
loses the game so after Bishop to E2 we
have Queen captures on F5 11 accepts the
challenge Knight the G5 now putting
pressure on that black queen and queen
to G6 with Knight D6 a beautiful Square
for the Knight but not uh attacking all
that much okay you will play a knight to
C7 with check but black is very happy
giving up the inactive Rook for the
active Knight and also for a chance to
attack White's King side so Knight to B6
and now we have Bishop to D3 here you
might be thinking okay how do we
continue here as it's a classical game
I'm just going to show you a few few fun
lines let's say Bishop captures and H5
if Rook captures Queen captures and now
of course if Queen captures you're gonna
deliver Knights to G6 and Knight to G7
check and pick up the queen so you're
probably gonna play Bishop captures on
E6 and now we will see Queen captures on
G6 Knight captures D captures and E6 and
then King D7 and you're gonna pick up
that E6 Pawn with a fairly equal cool
game on the other hand you could also
consider Knight the C7 check right away
let's say King the eight Knight captures
on A8 Knight captures and now just
Bishop to D3 to be
uh very annoying here or you could play
what uh takoti played right away and
that is Bishop to D3 and now how do you
react to this well of course you could
move the queen but where are you gonna
move the queen to queen to G4 does look
like something but okay then then you
force a queen trade black really doesn't
want to force a queen trade here black
wants to keep the center closed and
attack the white king so you might
consider something like Pawn to F5 but
then Rook captures uh not looking all
that great the only other movie Spawn to
E4 which is what the 11 played now comes
Knight to C7 check King to d8 and Knight
captures an A8 and this is the critical
moment of the game uh where you have so
many options uh you can already see that
the the Knight can be captured the
bishop can be captured uh what would you
play in this position it's such a such a
tricky one uh feel free to pause the
video and try to try to find uh you know
a plan for black hero how would you
proceed well I'll give you a couple of
seconds
yeah
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on going against
your basic urge to recapture and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is not Knight captures on A8 it
is not phone captures on D3 although you
can't play that it is actually Pawn to
H4 this is the strongest move for black
and uh the reason is of course how do
you how do you defend against Pawn
captures here well one way to do it and
pretty much the only way to do it is
Rook to F4 now how how do you react to
this well point is that if H captures on
G3 Now You're Gonna Play Bishop captures
and attack the black queen here but even
though this isn't very impressive Rook
captures an H2 with Chuck King to G1 and
now how do you okay your queen is still
hanging you can play something like
Bishop to F5 uh and now okay let's say
even Rook captures on F5 Knight captures
and now Rook to B1 you you've survived
the attack but chances are you will get
checkmated here but you don't even play
that after Rook to F4 there's even a
nicer way to replay and that is captures
on D3 and now after Knight characters on
B6 you will play a capture some B6 you
will even allow upon the G4 it's sort of
a not a tactical way to crush white but
a positional way to crush white and now
you will prevent white from playing H3
you will play H3 yourself and now you
will go after that G4 Pawn if Bishop to
D2 you will just prepare it Rook to G8
and now whatever white plays let's say
queen to F1 you put some pressure here
it doesn't really matter Bishop captures
on G4 and Rook captures on F6 is
impossible now because Queen D4 with
check and you will get checkmated now
very soon uh you have to go to G1 and
then you go under the mask of the of the
Rook so of course that's not not
happening so Rook D1 can be played but
now you just continue with Queen to H5
and white is basically without a move so
just completely crushing white
positionally uh even Bishop D2 might
happen uh so white will play something
like Rook to E3 to prevent the E2
because then Queen cap address and H3 is
possible but now you just continue with
your basic plan which is to push the
pawn to B5 there was your plan all along
and if Rook captures on D3 you play B
captures on c for now take away all the
squares from the rook and if Rook to G3
now Queen captures and D5 check King G1
and F5 and that's it black is pretty
much without a move the bishop helpless
the Rooks can't go anywhere uh also the
queen not not a lot of squares for that
Queen
uh you can play the king to C7 get the
Rook to d8 push the pawn here you could
also get the Knight into the game very
nice let's say in ig6 the E5 to D3 it
will be a beautiful Outpost for the
Knight this is just dead lost for white
um uh so you you basically choose how
you want to do it but in the game it
wasn't played he captures on D3 wasn't
played which is also very nice in the
game Knight captures and eight was
played and this allows wide back into
the game Bishop to E2 and now Pawn to H4
just isn't as potent because here you
can play G4 and if H3 you can play
Bishop to F for now already with the
threat of Bishop captures on D6 and if
King to C7 you can just play Queen to C1
and you don't have to worry about
anything if Rook to G8 trying to go
after the G4 Pawn even Queen to A3 now
with threats of Queen A7 or even Queen
captures on C5 as the D6 Pawn is pinned
uh black is just getting destroyed here
so here Bishop to H3 was played
attacking The Rook Rook G1 and now
Knight to B6 but now we have Bishop to
F4 putting pressure on the pawn here so
F5 defending it with the queen and now
Rook the B1 preparing to uh well
basically the idea is just Queen B3 and
you play a4a5 Kick away the Knight and
Captain B7 so King C7 trying to add some
Defenders there but it doesn't help
Queen to B3 we have Knight eat the C8
and now Pawn to a for A5 will dislodge
the Knight and then B7 just uh sorry
about that would be seven just hangs
Bishop to G4 and now Bishop captures NG
for age captures although it opens up
the H file isn't all that impressive
just A5 you're you're not in time to
organize anything on the king side so
Queen captures and G4 was played maybe
with some ideas of Queen F3 check but uh
Harsha just shows that it doesn't really
matter A5 now Queen F3 okay you could
play this and maybe even attack the
white king a little bit but it it
blunder I mean not doesn't blunder it
loses a piece and you will not gain
anything for your attack even just a
nice King to G1 to prevented this from
coming with a pin and the page captures
age captures you will play Queen H5
there will be one check but that's all
there is uh Queen A2 can be played now a
nice check King to F2 the queen is
hanging once the queen goes back you'll
move the Queen off for a trade Europa
piece completely winning so after A5
Knights the D7 was played now comes
Queen captures on B7 with check King 38
and now Rook beat the F1
stopping Queen F3 we have Pawn to E3
trying to get that pass Pawn up the
board but now Queen to B1 and now okay
if you play E2 just Rook to F2 and the
pawn will fall so after Queen to B2 Rook
the E8 was played but now just to Rook
the E1 with Pawn to E2 Rook to G2 and
here one last trick Queen to F3 now
although uh you cannot move the the G
Rook you could play Rook captures anyone
but look out just an E2 but this would
be a terrible blunder because of Queen
to F1 check Rook now has the block and
then you capture The Rook here and now
of course uh you are up a full piece and
completely winning but in the game of
course King the G1 was played and now
Queen to D3 and of course Rook G
captures an E2 we have Rook to G8 trying
to create some sort of uh uh tricky
position here but it doesn't work Queen
to B7 we have Queen captures and C3 and
Bishop to G5 with check real captures in
making it impossible due to Rook to E8
Checkmate so Knight to F6 was played but
now just Queen to F7 and he was in this
position on move 40 the 11 pencil
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here you have too many
too many threats here whatever you play
you're just gonna get checkmated very
quickly uh and even if you just give one
more check after King to H1 there are no
more checks and now you will have to
well there's absolutely nothing you can
do like any movie you play it's hard to
even imagine a move here I mean just
Bishop captures check now picks up the
queen uh so yeah and it would really be
pointless here for black so really a
brilliant brilliant victory for
hashabara takoti but in this position
after Knight captures and 8 was played
he did allow Pawn to H4 but you've seen
just how complicated it is and you
really really have to study the position
deeply in order to find all of the ideas
that were possible here but in the next
game 11 panzalaya retaliated with the
white pieces uh creating an even faster
uh win he won in 31 moves so they will
have to settle it in tie breaks and then
we will see who will proceed to round
two to face
some of the other players who have won
their encounter and also some of the
players will be paired with those in the
top 50 who were seated straight into
round two of the Fida World Cup 2023. uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh once again huge
congratulations for not going after the
Knight or the bishop and even
considering Ponte H4 that truly you know
shows that you have what it takes to be
a great player I would like to thank all
the games our best to Lynn Herbert said
Harper schlurture and Paul Harris for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
video World Cup until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day